today
i'm gonna tell you about the legend of
the frick
the frickening it's a tale of a freak
man
it's a tale of what the frick
fantasies this just can't ever that can
never be quenched
i'm talking of course about the frick
man himself
sammy sonic fan sammy
the freak spew it out at you
by freaking pull merchants
what the frick are you guys doing
sammy i'm sure a lot of you have seen
before but
do we really know the story about sammy
and what happened to sammy
i say what the frick let's jump
into it can't we have a radio pirate
classic sonic game
for crying out freaking loud sammy's
first video
began in april 2013 floated
his first review video a super mario
bros
wii review and let me freaking tell you
it's something to behold okay
marry the today week for a nintendo wii
okay this game was released back in 2009
it all seemed so innocent
until until it took a very dark turn
okay so let's get to the most important
aspect
creativity what the heck nintendo
the microphone how did he attain such
amazing audio quality
what the [ __ ] nintendo absolutely
perfect
now for the controls now for the
controls
motion controls did he just say heck and
not freak
what the frick i could listen to this
kid scream what the frick in my ears
in a thousand decibel all day long i
love it i live for it now sammy kept
making videos he can't make him review
videos
[Music]
you never know when he's gonna strike
he's basically the tyler1
of nintendo reviews
but some people did fight back against
sammy and his power
some people wrote essays
about why he's wrong oh god it keeps
going
about this review
and that's when the f day happened
the frickening came the world was about
to change
forever because sammy uploaded on may
24th
2013 stop criticizing
the wii u we know now that this is
before
he went through with the final
transformation you people cannot stop
criticizing the wii u
stop criticizing the wii u
i have it downstairs that's good to know
did he kill mario
he killed mario
mario blink if you're okay i like how he
says
stop criticizing the wii u or that he
has a gamecube whatever
he's a kid it doesn't matter i know i'm
just pointing out
i don't want to hear it stop chris
oh my god he just seriously what the
freak
gifts what the frick
someone needs to compile every time
sammy has said frick there's
you know the freaking you know the
freaking
damn call of duty is freaking freak it
deserves to freaking die
very harsh words you can tell he's angry
you can tell someone hurt this man
stop criticizing you
no damn it stop it
not the blanket don't throw the blanket
you [ __ ] freaks no you're a freaking
frick
you're a freak potato
accept it accepts nintendo accept the
review
3ds like nintendo live 3ds
like wii u and do me a favor and stop
criticizing okay
i'll stop what the actual hell am i
looking at here
[Music]
also one last thing i want to point out
to mike
to microsoft and so many fanboys okay
what is it
oh god oh god he's gone through he's got
the armor on he's got the backpack
what is that sword it's like a win
you're fighting a war
that you can't freaking win you're
microsoft and so many fanboys you
[ __ ] fricks
you think you stand a chance against
nintendo well guess what
we never stand a chance against you sam
please
you're freaking out not the fans
sammy no stamina
he doesn't know i'm a pc fan
we're going to win the war this is me
versus t-series we're gonna win the war
it's basically me i mean i don't know
i don't know why i'm even making fun of
this game and then finally
after saying stop criticizing wii u why
should you stop criticizing the wii u
quite criticizing the wii u
all right yes the wii u
is an amazing system and i own it
so i know because i own it
it's an amazing system because he owns
it absolutely incredible
you can't argue with facts and logics
stop crying liberals
sammy also did gameplay videos he did
let's plays
i mean he did like let's plays back in
2013 i mean that's that's on top of the
game son
and i would argue some of the finest
let's plays of all time sammy really
could have had a
future in video game let's play this
is not a speedway so don't make fun if i
don't
complete the level fast enough
that's right
[Music]
he just has a way with words doesn't he
let's get started
on this freaking frick
[Music]
[ __ ] stupid i know what it's like to
have a what the frick moment
while you're playing games but it
doesn't just end there
at the checkpoints
laugh don't laugh at samuel spain
everyone can relate to what the frick
moment
[Applause]
i would argue this is one of his finest
freak i'm somewhat of a freakazer
sam also reviews bad games
not just to rant but to make sure that
you don't buy the bad games don't waste
your money
sam really cares about you instead of
reviewing a good game i thought i'd
review a bad game
so people will know not to play it
you know you're the benders of the
skylanders franchise
then
[Music]
what a way to end the video jesus christ
i think i'll make that my new outro
[Music]
and then overall score zero out of ten
it's sad to see what happened to spyro
we've had a lot of buildup
we understand now to understand a man's
thought
to understand a man's pain we must
understand where these thoughts come
from
where these emotions build up from but
now
we're going into the deep end this is
the day
where universe change where the yin and
yang clashed and destroyed each other
stop hating on sonic uploaded july 15
2013. let's freaking
do this
[Music]
one sonic light solid white
i never seen a more compelling argument
for anything in my entire life
oh boy let's keep
stop watching on sonic for no
reason a demon a demon grows inside this
man
and he wants to come out best sonic game
ever
idiots
i'm so thankful that this exists can you
argue with that
you can't and that's not all people say
sonic is unappealing to the eye really
i'm pretty sure with all the sonic fan
fiction art that i've seen i don't think
people would say that
sonic is not appealing to the eye i
don't think anyone can make that point
isn't that enough
let it out sami let the demon out
it's basically me if i started making
videos
like three years earlier than i did
i know our games are still good yes
seriously and i'm going out here
let's get into the classic rant against
sonic fanbase you know what they say
you either die a hero you're living long
enough to become the villain
okay that is it this is the final
straw i've had with all the
freaking trolls no you freaking haters
no you freaking
sonic fan bricks you guys are the ones
don't ruin sonic for everyone
you're the one that said sonic wasn't
appealing to the eye i didn't mean to
for it's not my fault with freaking
sonic team because you freaking threats
just can't be captured be quenched
your fantasies can't ever be quick okay
it's so good i love it so much when
you're faced on your final judgment
basically the same script
when will he learn when will he learn
how does he go that high pitch i don't
know i think he's talking about all the
freaky fan art that comes out of sonic
there was like a meme at some point
people just making the most
despicable sonic fan art i mean i get it
i i'm fully 100
on sam's side here you've ruined the
sonic series
the side series is dead because of a
sonic fan base
i will forever hate the sonic fan
basically i'm dancing
for everything they do everything
i hate the sonic fanbase spider we need
us we don't need it
[Applause]
this video led to a lot of attention to
sammy and people started uh
hating on him he got some trolls people
saying that
he's uh not actually 15. i'm over
five feet tall this is me when someone
tells
tells me i'm short i'm over five feet
tall
but it seems that so over the years
sammy really he kind of calmed down
sonic the hedgehog
first of all what the frick
so different for the first one from
from idiots
to first of all what the freak
when the world needed him the most it
disappeared
i have awful news to reveal today
i i'm leaving the internet
but then a few years later
sammy has grown up and he returned and
it is an experience tell that i was
going to be really excited about that
especially sonic mania i
was basically saying hey i have
something planned for that because i
don't want something it's just great
went from frick to your daughter calls
me daddy too
our little sonic fan freak has grown up
sheds a single tear
he's gotten so calm over the years i'm
so proud of him our little frick has
become a little hot
what the hell what the frick sammy's all
grown up now
but i would like to ask sammy if you're
watching would you like to do me the
honor of
hosting meme review sonic memes
the people need to know your opinion on
sonic memes
i hope this video has been educational
now let sammy do the outro
get the freak out here get the freak out
what tuber simulator is becoming
relevant
no no don't leave
no please eagle please do something
yes
this game is still relevant god dammit
[Music]